this is a film about
ordinary normal people living in present
day who are drafted to fight a war
that's happening 40 years in the future
you
are our last
hope
and when we get literally dropped into
the future it's insanely intense
and when we first meet the white spikes
it's pretty gnarly
you know in the script the creature was
called a white spike and that was almost
the entirety of the description and so i
think we deduced that it needed to be
white and then it needed to somehow have
a split spike we really started with the
description of what the creatures needed
to do in the story but we really sort of
turned the artist loose and you know it
was very challenging because we're
trying to find a creature that was new
and fresh and that we hadn't seen before
and yet also had all of these very
lethal aspects to it but that really was
only the beginning of it you know then
there's a three-dimensional component of
it we have to understand how the
creature moves how it has its weight and
so we moved into a 3d environment with
that design once we did all that then we
had to do motion tests and understand
how it moved and how it could jump and
how fast it could move realistically
one of the things chris always told us
is you want to feel like just looking at
it is going to hurt you like if you just
brush up against this thing or if you're
too close to it you know something bad
is going to happen and so all of that
texture and sort of rotten quality of
the flesh and the fissures and the
cracks and the flakes you know all of
that we really dug into we took a lot of
inspiration in the design from lethal
creatures in our world
we looked at all different kinds of skin
surfaces rhinoceros skin hippopotamus
we looked at cheetahs and leopards for
the way that their joints allow them to
run quickly we looked at snakes for the
way their jaw might unhinge
and one of the things that you know
we're really proud of and that i think
the animators just did an incredible job
on is the facial presence of the
creature you know it has a bony face it
doesn't have a lot of flexibility and so
it doesn't emote in sort of the
traditional ways furrowing its brows
squinting its eyes or turning its
corners of its mouth up and down and so
you know with those limited controls the
animators were really
able to create a connection between the
audience and the creature and the other
characters in the movie and the
creatures and i think that's quite an
achievement for them yeah
it was a steep learning curve for our
animation team to really execute what
needed to be still convincing and
believable creature but outside of the
normal rule set the motion editing team
utilizes the upfront work that was
invested in our animation department to
really leverage the amount of different
type of behaviors whether it's leaping
jumping attacking we use this library
really to create like a very bespoke
approach to
animate hundreds of them in a very
effective and efficient way
to propagate into
large scenes and settings
one of our interesting challenges on
this movie is we had a number of
different vendors and we had to have the
appearance and the performance of the
creatures be the same throughout the
movie so we had weta doing the final
model of the creature and then they had
also done all of our motion tests and so
we shared that model and we shared those
motion tests with each of the different
teams including luma and they were able
to you know really kind of deliver the
kind of animation style and performance
you know that we needed and that matched
the other performances in the movie
all right dan i'm gonna need you to head
to the row of biomedical freezers along
the south wall in the lab
the stairwell was important because it's
really the first time that any of the
characters encounter the white spikes
one of the things i really wanted out of
the scene was to kind of destabilize the
audience a little bit so turn all the
music off like just had like natural
sounds going
as the sounds of the world kind of fade
away we lock in on dan's breathing and
that we're just isolated with him
so hollowness the echoes all this stuff
exemplify how they're feeling
you want it to feel like a haunted house
so it was set up to fulfill the
uneasiness and creepiness and the
audience they've done the math at this
point that the creature could kind of be
anywhere and could come out of anywhere
so they're really on pins and needles
and that's like to me that's the perfect
way of getting the audience like right
there leaning in
what the scene needed to do is needed to
show that they had some kind of
intelligence and some sort of
communication you know this scene really
was white spikes 101.
these white spikes have a language chris
said they have like a guttural clicking
something in the deep parts of their
abdomen their throat that generates this
clicking type of sound that they use to
bark orders to communicate across
distances
so we dug through tons of pack animals
wolves birds
dolphins
a recording of a pool sweeper it would
make this insanely gross kind of viscous
suction sound that then he would use to
envelop the beginning and ends of these
white spikes vocal phrases
when we're doing things like this and
we're working with the actors on set you
know there's no creature there we had a
puppet or we had a stand-in we had
something sometimes we'd have a stunt
person in there with the puppet acting
out the creature but it's always messy
you know then performers won't do
exactly what you expect them to do or
the camera operator won't do exactly
what you expect them to do
instead of looking at that as a mistake
we embraced it you know we found a way
to how do we justify this how do we use
this cool unexpected move you know to
reverse engineer into something that the
creature does that's unexpected there's
always this element of spontaneous
organic you know stuff just made the
thing feel more alive to me and that's
what i really loved about it
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] what you're seeing is some of it's
the set but most of it is a digital
creation done by jamie and his team the
other thing i think that the close
proximity the stairwell brought to the
scene was lighting the muzzle flashes
became a lighting source in and of
themselves
so i think that helped add to the
element of surprise and a lot of the
performance of the creatures
go
particularly in the hallway we had an
opportunity where we really wanted to
illustrate the relentlessness of the
creatures eventually culminating with
the moment with the axe you know we had
a really interesting animation challenge
there to understand you know that this
thing was heavy was being wounded and
then yet with every wound it was
changing its style so that it could
continue to move forward and threaten
our character you know until eventually
chris gets the upper hand so that was a
really fun challenge and something that
we worked very hard and had a lot of
back and forth on to make sure that we
really understood the power the
relentlessness of the creature
next all the bellies so only little part
on that body let's go
let's go overall the main thing that
attracted me to this project was the
story you know and chris wanting to tell
a very human story about this
relationship between
father and daughter and surrounding an
intimate story like that with visual
effects is not something that we see all
the time so that was a really great
opportunity and having the white spikes
be a character in the movie you know
really be the antagonist in in the movie
and have it have the creatures have
different forms with the males and the
females it just gave us so many
opportunities to bring those creatures
to life and to be such a big part of
that story so it's really satisfying
[Music]